[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the real reason
that the universe's in Dragon Ball super
are being erased by Zeno while we have
heard some reasons for why universe's
might be being erased such as when we
stels Vegeta and Goku that there were
once 18 universes altogether but six
were erased because Zeno was in a
spoiled mood or a bad mood we never
actually hear the reason for xennos
anger was he angry over some childish
thing or did something happen inside
these six universes that justified
xennos actions later on the grand priest
tells us that the losing universes in
the tournament of power will be erased
because Zeno thinks that there are too
many universes but that's not really a
complete answer
if Zeno thinks that there are too many
universes then why were these universes
created in the first place and what
exactly does the grand priest mean by
too many too many to keep track of too
many to keep under control
we just don't know but in this video I
will explain why I think that I have
figured out the real reason that some
universes need to be erased at least for
now I recently re-watched all of Dragon
Ball super and I think that the answer
for why the universes are really being
erased is given to us way back in the
very first arc in which goku faces off
against beerus and by the way i realize
that some people pronounce it beerus not
beerus but I've only ever seen Dragon
Ball super in subs so beerus with the
rolled R is much more natural to me
however of course we know that there are
different ways to pronounce things
different languages different accents
with which people speak so I think we
can all just agree to get along if you
enjoyed the Dragon Ball super content on
this channel and you want to see more be
sure to leave a like to let me know and
if you are new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you want to support
this channel and get cool anime merch at
the same time like keep calm and ultra
stinked or your girl calls me senpai you
can check out our merch store link in
the description and we are now posting
daily anime content on Twitter and
Instagram so you can follow us there at
anime uproar now one thing that really
struck me while watching episode 42 of
Dragon Ball super the episode in which
everyone is celebrating their victory
over universe 6 and that Monika shows up
even though beerus didn't want him to
and beerus decides to tell everyone the
truth about Monica
except for Goku is that when asked why
they all need to keep lying to Goku
beerus responds by saying that thinking
there is someone in the universe even
stronger than him will motivate Goku to
get stronger at this point wheeze says
something really interesting wheeze
warns everyone that if Goku doesn't get
stronger the earth could be in danger
because some of the gods of destruction
are dangerous this really made me wonder
why would we say that the earth is in
danger from other gods of destruction
when earth is in universe 7 and under
the jurisdiction of beerus theoretically
other gods of destruction have no
business causing problems for earth or
any other planet inside of universe 7 so
why does wheeze say this this made me
think back all the way to the first arc
in episode 12 in particular now just a
heads up if you watch the movie battle
of the gods and skip the first arc of
Dragon Ball super you would not have
seen a lot of the specific details about
the battle between goku and beerus
because not all of them are included in
the movie episode 12 is really
interesting the title of the episode is
the universe crumbles clash god of
destruction vs super saiyan god
in this episode beerus and goku and his
super saiyan god forum are fighting in
space above the earth and as they begin
to use more and more of their power
against each other the immense energy
they produced begins to create massive
shock waves and these shock waves get
stronger and stronger as they spread
throughout the universe everyone on
earth begins to feel the shock waves
elder kai and shin both feel the shock
waves and we even see certain planets
being
destroyed by the shockwaves the universe
begins to crumble under the force of the
two clashing energies and elder Chi
warns that a few more blows like that
and the entire universe will be
destroyed
thankfully the universe isn't destroyed
because beerus uses his power to negate
the effects of the explosion that would
have destroyed the universe but the fact
remains that the universe nearly came to
an end and entire planets were destroyed
as a result of this one battle that
involved a god of destruction now we
know that the twelve universes are all
connected and universe 7 is especially
connected to universe 6 as they are twin
universes and they even shared the super
Dragon Balls amongst themselves so if
the shockwaves that were being created
during the battle could have destroyed
universe 7 there is no guarantee that
they couldn't have also destroyed
universe 6 and perhaps even caused great
damage beyond that affecting even more
universes when we consider this then
wheezes warning that the earth could be
in danger because some gods of
destruction are dangerous makes sense
the destructive power that these
destroyers possess can annihilate an
entire universe and maybe even more than
one universe so this energy is
incredibly dangerous when it is being
used in a careless way we can say that
beerus himself was using it recklessly
during the battle which is why universe
7 came close to destruction in the first
place and later on in the anime we see
that other gods of destruction like
Sidra are willing to use their energy of
destruction carelessly with Sidra even
giving some of his energy away to an
assassin in order to kill Frieza before
the tournament I don't even need to
explain how reckless and dangerous it is
for a god of destruction to give such
potent destructive power to someone else
someone who could turn around and use it
in terrible ways and it is no wonder
that universe 9 and universe 7 have the
lowest mortal levels out of all the
universes the reason why these two
universes ranks so low is likely because
of the fact that they have wreckless
gods of destruction who pose a potential
threat to others and that brings me to
the big question why does any want to
erase
those universes that have the lowest
mortal levels I really don't think that
it's simply because there are too many
universes I think that Zeno and the
grand priest understand the danger posed
by certain gods of destruction
especially those in universes with low
mortal levels and they know that by
acting carelessly these gods of
destruction could destroy not only their
own universe but other universes as well
if they set off a particularly terrible
chain reaction something similar to the
shockwaves that were being generated in
the fight between beaters and Goku
these reckless gods of destruction could
potentially destroy all of existence and
I believe that this is the real reason
that Zeno must erase these universes
with the lowest mortal levels not
because there are simply too many of
them because then why would they be
created in the first place but rather
because these particular universes pose
a threat to all of existence the mortal
levels which I believe are determined by
the angel of each universe and I talked
about this in a previous video indicate
how stable and productive each universe
is the lowest-ranked universes are the
least stable and they have the most
careless and dangerous gods of
destruction and in order to protect all
of existence Zeno and the grand priests
feel that most of these universes need
to be erased the most unstable universes
must be erased in order to save the rest
this concept is similar to the idea of
cutting off one of the branches of a
tree that might be infected by a disease
in order to save the rest of the tree
let's think back to what happened at the
end of the Future Trunks arc when future
Zeno decided to erase the entire future
timeline when he sees that infinite
samus who has begun merging with the
universe and not only bad but because
all the universes are connected the mass
who is also merging with the entire
multiverse and even starting to break
into the present timeline future Zeno
decides that the only way to stop the
damage is to erase the entire future
timeline I believe that this is exactly
what present Zeno and the grand priests
are trying to avoid by erasing most of
universes with the lowest mortal levels
they are trying to make sure that the
dangerous gods of destruction and other
dangerous creatures within these
universes don't do the kind of damage to
the multiverse that infinite samus who
did which would lead to the destruction
of the entire timeline instead they want
to eliminate those universes that pose
the biggest threat to order and
stability of existence as a whole and if
this is true then I wonder if there is
more to the story about the six
universes that were already erased
earlier
did something happen within those
universes something that posed a threat
to the rest of existence and was this
the reason that Zeno got mad and decided
to erase them did a battle inside one of
those universes create the type of
destructive shockwaves that we saw in
episode 12
and these shockwaves spread to the six
universes before Zeno erased all six to
stop the damage from spreading to the
other twelve or did a villain like
infinite samaa soo emerge inside one of
those universes and managed to corrupt
those six before Zeno erased them to
stop the damage from spreading these are
the questions that I am really curious
about but whatever the truth may be I
think that erasing some universes in
order to protect the others from danger
makes a lot more sense for Zeno than
erasing universes just because he is in
a bad mood or just because there are too
many of them but let me know what you
guys think do you agree with me that the
real reason that the universe is with
the lowest mortal level are being erased
is to protect the other universes and
the rest of existence from a future
threat that could lead to the
destruction of the entire timeline and
the other question that I want to pose
to you guys is why do you think that the
six other universes were erased what is
the real truth behind what happened
there let me know your thoughts down in
the comments I always love hearing from
you if you enjoyed this video I want to
see more videos like it be sure to leave
a like to let me know and if you're new
to the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell we are
now posting daily anime con
and on Twitter and Instagram so be sure
to follow us there at anime uproar both
links are in the description as always
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]